oh c'est avec des étoiles plein les yeux
que les petits saint quentinois ont
répondu à l'invitation de leurs
personnages préférés
t'choupi pour les 30 ans de la librairie
le pavé du canal il est venu rencontrer
ces jeunes lecteurs impressionné que l
on regarde le ciel at-elle effet bv6 il
a son propre dessin animé mais son
succès vient d'une série de livres
jeunesse illustré par thierry courtin
j'oubliais y raconte ses aventures du
quotidien des fois il ya des enfants par
exemple ils sont peu peur d'aller à
l'école où ils ont peur de quitter tout
doux ils ont peur de quitter la tétine
et tout ça et puis bah avec les livres
ben moi je partager avec eux ce qui
m'est arrivé les pays comme ça y est
c'est plus facile pour eux les enfants
et leurs parents étaient nombreux ce
héros des petits remporté un réel succès
bien plus que notre journaliste que tu
peux me dire ton nom et ton âge
un joli souvenir pour les saint
quentinois qui repartent chacun avec une
dédicace et une nouvelle photo de
famille